here with more someone who deals with
the mob every single day
is not enough money and printed by the
government to actually
be worth doing this job white house
press secretary kelly mcaney is with us
by the way i wanted to say i did not
know the story of your personal story
that you shared at the convention
and i want to applaud you because that
obviously
that's i'm sure that wasn't an easy
thing to do but i'm also
certain that you help a lot of people my
mom
suffered stage four breast cancer she
survived it barely
and she since passed away from something
else but i thought that was very brave
and i think you're going to help a lot
of people by doing that
thank you sean your mom was a fighter
women across this country are fighters
who are battling breast cancer
it was my honor to share the story and
my honor that president trump
was the one who encouraged me to do it
let's talk
i watched these crowds and it's not just
kenosha wisconsin
it's everywhere the president goes
lining the streets
mile after mile after mile i actually
had a secret source inside the motorcade
that sent me video that i can't air
it's mile after mile you had a chance to
speak to people you saw the reaction
kenosha was so glad the president came
versus what the media would say oh he
can't go he can't go the number he can't
go
well he went and he's helping kenosha
out and he also restored
law and order there that's right of
course the media won't share this but we
literally rode for 15 miles sean
and literally person after person with
pro-trump signs
showing up showing their support in a
district that is a democrat district
that no one since richard nixon
had won but president trump did and then
we arrive at this
we arrive in kenosha he stands at a
business that was burned down they'd
been open for 109
years but they were burned down by
antifa
rioters then we move on and we go to law
enforcement where we meet with u.s
marshals
our brave local law enforcement and i
saw this woman and she was
a little shy and you know i was talking
to the u.s marshals and i moved on and i
came back
after the president passed through and
they were there's this woman crying
the same woman who was a little shy and
nervous uh crocodile tears they had
their arms on her back and i said what
what
happened over here and they said
president trump came over spoke to her
gave her a little pin from the white
house and she's stunned she's humbled
and she's honored that this is what the
commander-in-chief
did for a woman from jackson mississippi
that's the respect this president has
for our men and women in this country
and i see it every day oh i'm looking at
this video right now
of one of the burned down businesses and
i'm looking
you know i know friends that have
business every single
thing they have in life they usually
throw into that business including their
heart sweat equity and soul
and it gets burned to the ground look
kenosha got the help little late but
they got the help
and the president restored law and order
president did it in d.c the president
did it in minnesota
he's been begging new york chicago
seattle portland l.a
to help they keep refusing the help
why when people's lives are destroyed
and people are dying
it's a great question and look governor
evers to his credit finally did request
the help but
you know as was said today what if he
had requested it 24 hours
earlier this business that had been open
for more than a century
would still be there what if mayor
wheeler the derelict
mayor irresponsible mayor out in
portland who's seen violence in the
streets for 100 days had requested that
help
that beautiful young boy who lost his
life in the streets a trump supporter
who was sought out and gunned down by a
100 percent antifa individual in his
words
would still be here it's lawlessness and
democrat governors and mayors need to
step it up
i hope but i just want to add to what i
said in the beginning
you yours odds after you got this test
84 percent some point in your life you
would have had breast cancer
i just would urge women i don't know
what the test is i'm not a doctor but if
you have that in your family i hope
people hear that message thank you